pour moi je pense qu'on est comme une
guerre aujourd'hui on est entré en
guerre contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi
vient n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi c'est
nous
[Musique]
semaine agitée en biélorussie après la
réélection contestée du président
lukashenko double rassemblement
aujourd'hui la minsk le premier a réuni
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
soutien au chef d'état biélorusse
le second plusieurs milliers pour
contester les résultats du scrutin
présidentiel masque obligatoire
confinement réinstaurer ou prolongées
établissements fermés dans le monde un
peu partout où les mesures sanitaires
contre le kobe 19 se renforce
objectif contrer une éventuelle deuxième
vague de l'épidémie
[Musique]
la france reprend l'attribution des
visas aux libanais par solidarité
annonce du quai d'orsay aujourd'hui le
service était jusqu'ici suspendue en
raison de la crise sanitaire dans le
pays
le liban qui panse toujours ses plaies
douze jours après la double explosion de
beyrouth qui a fait 171 morts et plus de
6000 blessés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous ne
retrouvez sur arte france
une semaine jour pour jour après la
réélection d'alexandre loukachenko la
biélorussie est toujours confronté à un
mouvement de contestation inédit
aujourd'hui les partisans du chef d'état
biélorusse ont défilé à minsk pour
soutenir leur pouvoir depuis 26 ans
manifestation marquée par la présence du
premier ministre du président du sénat
et d'alexandre loukachenko lui même il
en a profité pour appeler à défendre
l'indépendance du pays
dans le même temps l'opposition a aussi
tenu à faire entendre sa voix en
participant à une marche de la liberté
le président biélorusse qui s'est une
nouvelle fois entretenu ce dimanche avec
vladimir poutine
alexandre loukachenko a déclaré qu'une
aide complète sera fourni par la russie
pour assurer la sécurité du pays
résultat contesté des parts de la
principale opposante vers la lituanie
manifestations monstre la biélorussie a
connu une semaine agitée depuis la
réélection à un sixième mandat du
président loukachenko
retour sur les faits en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
à
i
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toujours au sujet de la biélorussie
l'union européenne a intérêt à prendre
des précautions si elle ne veut pas que
la chine s'en mêle parce que pékin joue
un rôle important dans l'économie à
biélorusse
c'est la conviction de martin mc cauley
experts de la rue 6 d'un point de vue
moral
l'union européenne estime qu'elle se
doit d'agir elle doit soutenir ceux qui
ont manifesté
car c'est un droit démocratique mais du
point de vue des intérêts de l'union
européenne elle se doit d'être très très
prudente face à cette situation très
délicate
elle ne souhaite pas faire basculer la
biélorussie dans le chaos et l'union
européenne voit la biélorussie comme un
état intermédiaire entre la russie et
l'occident et entre la chine et
l'occident et la chine joue désormais un
rôle important dans l'économie
biélorusse donc une autre façon pour
l'union européenne de sanctionner la
biélorussie serait à travers des
sanctions financières
parce que la biélorussie à quelque chose
comme 10 milliards de dollars de dettes
en liquidités et elle doit emprunter à
des banques des banques occidentales
pour payer le service de cette dette
l'union européenne pourrait donc dire
non vous n'aurez pas cet argent ce qui
se produirait alors eh bien c'est que
cela reviendrait à inviter les chinois
dans l'histoire les chinois seront ravis
de venir proposer cet argent et une fois
que les chinois seront dans la place ils
vont jouer un rôle plus important en
france le coville 19 signe une
progression inédite 3310 nouveaux cas en
24 heures c'est le pire bilan depuis lé
déconfinement est les entreprises serait
le principal foyer de contamination
la ministre du travail a dévoilé
plusieurs mesures pour tenter d'enrayer
la propagation du virus en milieu
professionnel
elisabeth bornes qui souhaitent proposer
le port du masque obligatoire en
entreprise
des mesures jugées insuffisantes pour le
corps médical qui demande plus de
rigueur
généraliser le port du masque en
extérieur fermer certains commerces
interdiction de fumer sur la voie
publique à face à la hausse du nombre de
cas de contamination
plusieurs pays ont renforcé leurs
mesures de restriction pour éviter une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie qu hélène
masquelier et robin paris
musclée à nouveau son dispositif pour
contrer une résurgence de la pandémie
la décision prise par de nombreux états
à travers le monde à l'image de la grèce
qui a opté pour la fermeture des bars et
restaurants dès minuit dans les régions
les plus touchées par le coït 19
c'est le cas notamment sur l'île très
touristique de mykonos au moins pour une
semaine ici à mykonos nous pensons que
c'est une grande erreur de fermer les
commerces et minuit parce qu'il ya un
grand nombre de gens survivent et on ne
peut pas en avoir 50 mille soixante
mille qui se rendent dans la ville de
mykonos en l'espace d'une heure il
pourrait étendre les horaires en italie
des villes côtières ont imposé de
nouvelles restrictions fermeture des
discothèques ou encore généralisation du
port du masque en extérieur au danemark
également les masques seront
obligatoires dans les transports à
partir du 22 août en espagne pays
européens actuellement le plus touché le
gouvernement a annoncé un durcissement
des mesures
la première mesure adoptée concerne la
vie nocturne et la fermeture des
discothèques des salles de danse et des
bars à cocktails avec ou sans concert de
musique en direct dans toute l'espagne
l'heure de fermeture de tous les
restaurants et bars de l'ensemble du
secteur de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration est fixé à une heure du
matin
il est interdit de fumer sur la voie
publique ou dans les espaces extérieurs
lorsqu'une distance interpersonnelles
minimale de 2 mètres ne peut être
respectée plusieurs pays dont la gestion
de la première vague a été saluée sont
désormais inquiet face à la résurgence
du virus
vendredi la nouvelle zélande à prolonger
de douze jours le confinement d'auckland
la plus grande ville du pays
à séoul les rencontres sportives devront
désormais se tenir à huis clos pour
contenir la flambée épidémique
la corée du sud a enregistré 2 179
nouveaux cas ce dimanche
la hausse la plus importante depuis le
début du mois de mars
je suis inquiet les chiffres décliner
est à présent de voir cette importante
augmentation cela m'inquiète
j'espère que les gens font attention à
leur hygiène individuel portent des
masques et respecte la distanciation
sociale
des mesures renforcées un peu partout
pour prévenir l'éventualité d'une
deuxième vague
même si le terme n'est encore prononcées
qu'à demi mot par les dirigeants des
pays concernés
al'inverse d'autres états s'avance vers
un déconfinement à l'instar de l'algérie
qui a commencé samedi à rouvrir ses
mosquées ses plages parquet restaurant
après cinq mois de restriction la chine
la france les états-unis l'australie
tous participent à la course au vaccin
contre le coc but 19 et à la surprise
générale c'est la russie qui a
revendiqué la découverte du tout premier
vaccin contre le virus médias ce qui fit
trouver une solution rapide pour contrer
la pandémie de coronavirus un objectif
majeur pour plusieurs laboratoires voir
des structures étatiques comme
l'institut gamaleya de moscou vladimir
poutine a annoncé cette semaine le
développement par les experts du pays
d'un vaccin efficace nommé spoutnik v
celui ci serait actuellement en phase
finale d'essais cliniques
le locataire du kremlin a précisé que sa
propre fille avait participé à
l'expérience en se faisant inoculé le
sérum le ministre russe de la santé a
indiqué que le vaccin serait destiné
dans un premier temps en soignant avant
d'être mise à disposition des
volontaires
de leur côté les états unis ont misé fin
juillet sur le duo pharmaceutique sanofi
et gsk un investissement de plus de 2
milliards de dollars pour tenter de
bénéficier d'un vaccin anti coved 19 le
plus vite possible
le contrat en question prévoit la
fourniture de 100 millions de doses à
destination des américains dans le même
temps l'union européenne a décidé de
réserver 300 millions de doses du même
vaccin
le royaume uni s'est arrangé pour
recevoir 60 millions d'unités région du
monde la plus touchée par la pandémie
l'amérique latine s'activent elle aussi
pour tenter de trouver des solutions
cette semaine l'argentine et le mexique
ont annoncé un compromis afin de
produire le vaccin du laboratoire
astrazeneca entre 150 et 250 millions de
doses seront fournis aux pays concernés
à l'exception du brésil en fonction des
résultats des tests prévus pour la fin
de l'année
l'objectif est de livrer la version
finale au premier semestre 2021
d'après les argentins cette combinaison
du privé
et compriment le fait que ce vaccin sera
vendu sans aucun profit signifie que
nous pouvons le faire rapidement que
nous pouvons le rendre bon marché et
accessible à tous la vérité est donc que
ce projet a que des avantages et des
choses à nous apprendre aussi pour
l'avenir
en février nous enverrons là bas les
antigènes produit ici les principes
actifs et là aussi le remplissage prend
du temps le vaccin doit être distribuée
il doit être approuvé par les autorités
je pense que ce sera davantage aux
alentours du milieu du semestre
disons que c'est ce que nous visons la
phase 2 a eu un taux de réussite de 91 %
ce qui est très élevé et avec deux doses
il atteint 100 % ce qui a donné à tout
le monde l'espoir de pouvoir dire allons
de l'avant en prenant des risques
en asie la chine test un vaccin en
indonésie depuis plusieurs semaines le
gouvernement indonésien qu'on produire
250 millions de doses près de 1600
volontaires participent aux essais
cliniques de phase 3 qui devrait se
poursuivre encore pendant plusieurs mois
d'ici janvier 2021 nous prévoyons de
produire entièrement les vaccins et si
nous sommes prêts nous les distribuerons
à tous les habitants du pays
on veut pouvoir vacciner toute notre
population c'est difficile de créer son
propre vaccin c'est pour cela que celui
ci nous l'avons acheté en mai dernier
l'agencé européenne du médicament avait
estimé qu'un vaccin pourrait être
disponible d'ici une année
dans un scénario qu'elle juge optimiste
d'après l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
sur les 167 projet lancé à l'échelle du
globe
seuls 8 serait en cours de finalisation
la france reprend l'attribution des
visas aux libanais par solidarité à
nancy du quai d'orsay aujourd'hui le
service était jusqu'ici suspendue en
raison de la crise sanitaire dans le
pays
le ministère français des affaires
étrangères précise néanmoins que
l'accueil des ressortissants libanais
elle se fera dans le respect le plus
strict des mesures sanitaires à la suite
des explosions survenues sur le port de
beyrouth le 4 août 2020 la france a
décidé de reprendre à titre exceptionnel
le traitement et la délivrance des visas
au bénéfice des ressortissants libanais
résidant au liban sans autre restriction
que les conditions habituelles
d'admission au séjour et d'autoriser à
nouveau la rentrée sur son territoire ce
geste de solidarité à l'égard du peuple
libanais est effectué dans le plus
strict respect des exigences sanitaires
les personnes de 11 ans ou plus venant
du liban pays de circulation active du
virus devront se soumettre à un test pcr
à leur arrivée en france en cas de test
positif
les personnes devront réaliser une
quatorzaine la diaspora libanaise
mobilisés à paris un rassemblement
aujourd'hui près de l'ambassade du liban
en france
objectif dénoncer le système multi
confessionnel et soutenir le pays qui
panse toujours ses plaies
douze jours après la double explosion de
beyrouth qui a fait 171 morts et 6000
blessés
ces manifestants ont par ailleurs réagi
à la reprise de l'attribution de visas
français pour les libanais le peuple
aussi n'est pas naïve politiquement
quand on fait ça c'est aussi pour vider
la population de la branche qui peut
être faire le changement et donc qui
pourra elle construire un nouveau liban
donc ce que ce que fait la france
politiquement et comme toutes les forces
aussi c'est des manigances pour
maintenir ce même système confessionnel
et de changer la démographie internes du
pays nous sommes contre l'ingérence
directe dont toutes les payer quelle que
soit la france où l'amérique ou la
russie où là où n'importe quel payer nos
sommes contre l'ingérence des pays tiers
au dpi étrangères au liban
il ne faut pas les aider à partie
il faut les aider à rester tout en les
aidant à constituer un nouveau
gouvernement
on n'a pas besoin que les ergots les
jeunes qui pour venir parce que la
france est un beau pays non non on a
besoin qu'il reste la ram et la france
de soutenir et de les soutenir de plus
en plus aujourd'hui au niveau sociétal
il faut quand même essayer de se battre
pour vraiment même si on est en france
ou au liban que d'essayer de
reconstruire un état libanais qui soit
vraiment souvent vous verrez la semaine
prochaine donald trump durci le ton
après le rejet du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu de prolonger l'embargo sur les
ventes d'armes à l'iran le président
américain promet de recourir au snack
bac une forme de droit de veto à
l'envers explications d'hélène masculine
et une voix en leur faveur celle de la
république dominicaine sur la totalité
des membres du conseil de sécurité
c'est le seul soutien que les états unis
ont réussi à obtenir pour voter leur
résolution
tous les alliés européens de washington
se sont eux abstenus
une véritable démonstration de désaccord
avec la stratégie iranienne de donald
trump
mais le président américain furieux ne
compte pas en rester là
nous savions ce qu'allait être l'issue
du vote mais nous allons faire un snack
bac
vous verrez ça la semaine prochaine oui
vous verrez ça la semaine prochaine le
président poutine veut organiser un
sommet en vidéoconférence y participerez
vous probablement pas non je pense que
nous voulons attendre après les
élections
écoutez l'iran veut tellement que je
perde vous savez que l'iran c'est une
toute autre histoire en ce moment le
snap bac est une forme de droit de veto
employés à l'envers mais pour en
bénéficier
les etats unis doivent faire reconnaître
leur statut de pays participants au
texte sur le nucléaire iranien
un accord dont ils se sont retirés en
2018 en cas de succès concernant cette
manoeuvre
washington pourrait imposer le
rétablissement des sanctions de l'onu
contre téhéran
en attendant l'iran savoure cette gifle
diplomatique infligé aux américains
à mon avis cette journée restera dans
l'histoire de notre iran et dans
l'histoire de la lutte contre
l'arrogance mondiale
regardez à quel point les états unis
sont humiliés le pouvoir de l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien qui a
été endommagée par les crimes des états
unis et d'israël et qui restent à moitié
vivant a vaincu les états unis de son
côté le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou a dénoncé une
décision scandaleuse
si les états unis décident d'enclencher
le snap bac un long contentieux pourrait
alors être déclenchée et au final venir
affaiblir le rôle même des nations unies
en tant qu'institution derrière cette
manoeuvre américaine certains voient la
volonté de donald trump de rendre
impossible un éventuel retour des
américains dans cet accord au cas où il
ne serait pas réélu en novembre prochain
le nucléaire iranien a encore de
l'entretien téléphonique entre le chef
de la diplomatie russe et son homologue
américain sergueï lavrov et mike pompeo
ont notamment discuté de la proposition
de vladimir poutine de se réunir avec
les pays du format 5 + 1 pour éviter la
détérioration de la situation dans la
région
la partie russe a confirmé son soutien
total de la résolution 2231 du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies qui a créé
le cadre juridique international pour la
mise en oeuvre du plan d'action global
commun pour le règlement du programme
nucléaire iranien
ça gagne lavrov a souligné que la
conclusion de cet accord en 2015 était
une réalisation politique et
diplomatique majeure visant à renforcer
le régime de non-prolifération des armes
nucléaires et la sécurité régionales
dans la région du moyen-orient
la poste américaine au coeur de la
bataille de l'élection présidentielle du
3 novembre à donald trump multiplie les
attaques contre l' agence postale
le président américain ne crois pas au
vote par correspondance pour lui elle
c'est la porte ouverte aux fraudes
massives
il refuse donc de lui octroyer une aide
d'urgence
elle qui déclare être dans
l'impossibilité d'assurer la livraison
des bulletins de vote
de leur côté les démocrates accusent
donald trump de vouloir saboter
l'élection présidentielle en limitant le
vote par correspondance
on écoute le locataire de la maison
blanche comme vous le savez les
démocrates n'approuve pas le financement
nécessaire aux services postaux et ils
n'approuvent pas non plus le financement
nécessaire à cette chose ridicule qui
veulent faire qui est un vote totalement
par correspondance on pourrait l'appeler
vote par correspondance universel
encore une fois le vote par
correspondance et une choses excellentes
si je suis un électeur qui vote par
correspondance
c'est parce que j'ai demandé et obtenu
puis envoyé mon bulletin cela fonctionne
donc très bien c'est ce que nous avons
eues mais maintenant ils veulent envoyer
des millions et des millions des
bulletins de vote
et voyez ce qui va se passer ils seront
perdus ils seront jetés on les
retrouvera en temps ça va être un
désastre
la perspective de ce vote par
correspondance inquiète donald trump
selon françois costantini si les
géopolitologue on est à moins trois mois
deux mois et demi du tutu scrutin que en
effet la crise du co à vis d'eux étant
ce qu'elle est en général et et aux
états unis en particulier le vote par
correspondance serait particulièrement
sollicités donc en effet c'est un enjeu
essentiel pour la première fois on
verrait très peu de files devant les
bulletins de vote et ce vote serait
quasiment décisionnel en effet en termes
d'élections du fait de sa
proportionnalité tout à tout à fait
nouvelle donc en effet il ya une
défiance de tournelles trump puisque des
sondages ont été faits et il indique que
les votant par correspondance très
pratiquement à plus des deux tiers pour
byden et moins d'un tiers voire moins
d'un cinquième pour pour donald trump
donc en effet le lobe par correspondance
c'est peut-être le le combat préalable
aux potes du premier mardi 2 novembre
l'accord émirats arabes unis israël va
tuer la solution à deux états est
éloigné la possibilité d'une paix
israélo-palestiniennes déclaration de
l'autorité palestinienne aujourd'hui
après l'annoncé de l'accord de
normalisation des relations entre abou
dhabi et tel aviv accord salué par les
occidentaux mais dénoncée par l'iran et
les palestiniens à gaza les partisans du
front démocratique pour la libération de
la palestine ont défilé dans les rues du
centre ville aujourd'hui ils ont mis le
feu à des photos de donald trump de
benyamin netanyahou et du prince
héritier d'abou dhabi ces images
similaires également au pakistan où ils
étaient plusieurs centaines à soutenir
la cause palestinienne ce dimanche à
karachi au sud du pays est les
manifestants scandaient des slogans
hostiles à israël
pas de reconnaissance de l'état hébreu
par le pakistan
tant que les intérêts de la palestine ne
seront pas respectés ont-ils clamé une
résolution du conflit
israélo-palestinien est considéré par
beaucoup comme un préalable à la paix
entre israël et l'ensemble du monde
arabe et musulman pour en parler avec
nous un michel raimbault essayiste et
ancien ambassadeur de france
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors sans surprise cet accord entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis ne
fait pas l'unanimité les réactions
internationales sont nombreuses
pour certains il s'agit d'un accord
historique quand d'autres parlent de
trahison votre analyse sur le sujet ce
que cet accord va encore fragilisé la
position palestinienne
conques est d'accord pagé ligne sont
palestinienne
il n'avait déjà pas besoin d'un tel
accord là c'est simple parce qu on note
un manque de réaction des autorités
l'autorité palestinienne on est toujours
finalement à menacer spéciale est donc
finalement que l'on consent le champ
libre
moi je note finalement l'accord qui doit
être signé entre israël et les émirats
arabes unis s'est inscrit dans la vaste
mouvement jaloux le grand amour entre
tous les pays du golfe notamment les
émirats arabes unis mais tous les pays
du golfe et l'arabe saoudite et l'état
d'israël une normalisation ses consignes
auraient un petit peu paumé top du top
de la diplomatie et en font tout se
passe comme si c'était la preuve que il
a dans cet état du golfe où la pète pas
bloquant mais il a besoin de succès on
peut réussir
m mais c'est également un succès pour la
tania look est lui aussi en grande
difficulté mme thibout est par contre
pour tous les états du golfe s'est passé
quelque chose ça traduit seulement un
grand mouvement contre l'iran pablo peu
tous les états du golfe dont l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats arabes unis
finalement créé le conseil de
coopération du golfe à 80 était
directement plus de la raison des contre
la plante iranienne c'était la première
traduction une miracle diplomatique par
lequel les états arabes où certains
états a parmi les intrants vision
l'espoir ils ont considéré que l'ennemi
le rythme était plus mais l'été l'iran
alors finalement on notera que tous les
annonciades club des monarchies du
conseil de coopération du golfe
puisqu'il avait été question et turque
au dessus de faire deux membres associés
royaume du maroc
or si elle est brune sujet michel
raimbault expliquez-nous alors vous
l'avez évoqué il ya quelques minutes
expliqué nous quel rôle ont joué les
états unis dans dans cet accord entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis eau
je crois que c'était plein succès
d'abord ça favorise israël puisque je
pense monsieur tonnes qui est beaucoup
sensible aux intérêts d'israël mais
également le sien c'est quelque chose
qui est de la réalisation de la
transaction du siècle
les émirats roussel très très ambigu
finalement dans la région on sait pas
ils sont des partisans ouverture
d'antenne campagne présent pour le
contrôle des ports de la région et
ailleurs dans le monde arabe
finalement ils croient que c'est lui un
succès pour nous outre m pour l'instant
on voit bien d'abord que la cérémonie le
rappel annoncé cet accord il y avait la
partie battons-nous jared kushner boujon
président de l'apr la is an de l'accord
de l'autre la contraction du siècle mais
ils refont nos père également cet accord
du sel clients une antenne est à peine
plus tôt réconciliation entre israël
joue un rôle de fer de lance est
maintenant connu qu'on comprend pas très
bien le werder politique elle est
compensée par une place au soleil dans
la région est ce que d'autres pays
arabes pourraient prochainement suivre
l'exemple des émirats arabes unis et
normaliser leurs relations avec l'état
hébreu et si oui lesquelles
on va écouter tous les états du golfe
devraient suivre je pense un bagel du
les uns après les autres à la culotte
parce que ça ferait mauvais effet si les
impôts
une ceinture apprendre tous nous
emmerdent envies d'ailleurs autant qu'il
veut faire d'un seul coup ça éviterait
le suspense diplomatique
et puis d'autres parce qu'ils étaient
moins évidentes ou c'est ce qui va pas
de choix c'est l'aspect si le baroque ce
poignet est finalement au mouvement en
signant un accord également de
reconnaissance d'israël puisque certains
l'annoncent mais je n'ose que par
exemple le journal d'annoncés ces jours
derniers sinon aujourd'hui une teignouse
d'un journaliste reich bien plus que son
degré divers styles bien et dont il
serait le maroc concerne un certain
nombre d'arguments normalisait petit spa
notamment la présence d'une communauté
marocaine importante en israël et puis
au fond la modération on prête au
souverain marocain est encore une fois
samedi pour l'instant c'est pas donné
parce que dans tous les états ou bien à
voir quel que soit le grand mouvement
d'amour les dirigeants arabes du golfe
et des monarchies arabes pour l'état
d'israël c'est pas une amitié partagé
dans la population
les mauvais esprits et les rappelle que
même en egypte qui n'est pas une
monarchie mais qui a elle signé un
accord mission d rapidement puisque
l'interview touche à sa fin rapidement
emmanuel macron à s'est entretenu
aujourd'hui avec mahmoud abbas président
de l'autorité palestinienne le président
français affirme lui avoir dit sa
détermination à oeuvrer pour la paix au
proche orient à ce que la la voix de la
france pèse suffisamment pour contribuer
à la résolution du conflit israélo
palestinien ou goûter la voix de la
france pour la ceinture et structures
très ambigu comment elle pouvoir pour le
liban finalement il ya beaucoup de gens
qui prennent les arrière pensées au plan
devant 105 ch parce qu'ils ont manqué
l'on nous conduisons peut-être pas tout
à fait tort est en tout cas la position
de la france est en vue
la france soutient israël malgré
quelques réserves finalement globalement
aucune mesure une mesure qui peut servir
israël propre et la sympathie de la
france sous le couvert de paie fort je
ne pense pas que surtout la voie de la
paix et que la solution à comparaître au
bruit n'est pas finalement et que les
palestiniens restent à débattre au sol
passez au style yang héritage michel
rambo merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
essayiste et ancien ambassadeur de
france
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve dans un peu plus d'une demi
heure
[Musique]
le grave incident du digeon entre une
frégate française et des navires de
combat turc doit nous faire prendre
conscience de l'évolution inquiétant de
la situation en méditerranée orientale
nous sommes confrontés un président turc
qui résonne exclusivement en aura pas de
danse tout y considère l'europe comme un
adversaire qu'il a toujours réussi à
faire plier en pariant qu'il n'y aura
jamais d escalade avec des alliés il
continue à affirmer une lyre
diplomatico-militaire indépendante par
rapport à ses alliés de l'otan tout en
se déclarant un membre totalement fiable
de cet organisme
la négociation sera difficile avec un
interlocuteur qui n'hésite pas à se
mettre sur la ligne rouge pour forcer le
destin